l on reste dans le domaine médical
puisque dans quelques jours une équipe
strasbourgeoise devrait réaliser sur
l'homme la première opération assistée
par ordinateur 2 c'est le nom du robot
permet une télé manipulation à distance
initialement il faut le savoir c'est une
idée et un projet de l'armée américaine
jérôme soûlard sylvain gauthier une
caméra miniature très performante qui
évite le risque et le traumatisme d'une
éventration pour le patient les offres
bref une image quasi parfaite et précise
qui se déplace en suivant le simple son
de la voix auprès du chirurgien
sp le geste du practicien relayé à
distance par ce bras articulé au dixième
de centimètres beaucoup plus précis donc
que la main de l'homme à strasbourg
depuis quelques mois on expérimente sur
l'animal la médecine du troisième
millénaire
l'opération assistée par ordinateur
c'est vrai que lorsque l'on utilise ses
fastes paiement c'est d'une heure grande
facilité d'utilisation et d'une grande
précision qui nous permet de penser que
dans le futur on pourra difficilement se
passer ce genre d'instrument zus n'est
évidemment pas un robot qui aux
personnes mais bien une technique de
télé manipulation qui obéit parfaitement
à l'homme que le patient se trouve à
deux mètres comme ici ou à l'autre bout
du monde davantage dans ce cas de figure
c'est sûrement pas de dire on va se
faire opérer par quelqu un à dix mille
kilomètres mais c'est ce qu'on appelle
le thé les compagnonnages tout le monde
sait que dans une intervention
chirurgicale pour dix minutes soit un
quart d'heure dans une période
particulièrement difficile
on a souvent et les gens souvent besoin
d'une haine et cette aide elles existent
déjà par les moyens de visioconférence
est ce qu'on appelle le télé mentoring
c'est que le chirurgien fait appel à un
autre changent et à plus experts qui lui
donne des conseils et bien outre ses
conseils le chirurgien vont pouvoir
prendre les manettes et opéré à distance
pendant 10 minutes ou pendant un quart
d'heure
avec un simple scanner d'ici quelques
semaines l'ordinateur pourra également
permettre une incroyable vision en trois
dimensions à l'intérieur même d'un
organe vital à soigner que le chirurgien
pour à scruter dans tous les sens pour
prendre la meilleure décision
la première opération d'un homme par
machine interposés est prévue pour cette
année entre strasbourg et new york